we're headed up to the northern part of
Israel where residents around these
areas are very worried about ongoing
hisbah
attacks the people that we meeting
around here are saying that in the past
week There's been more and more risk
more and more people that are leaving
the
city
[Music]
for
so right now we're at kabut gim where
people have come from all around the
community to prepare food for these
really
soldiers it's important for them to have
like something even what for once a day
something good to eat and to see other
people and to see the civilians do all
this stuff the people here are saying by
cooking food for the soldiers and just
trying to help out it's easing the
tension of being so close to the
potential fighting that's all around
them
yesterday we had a alarm here and all of
we had all of us and more people in this
place it's not very safe we get used to
the bombs here
yeah there is no other option except
from winning this War I think and this
is what we feel here so we do what
whatever we can to raise the the
morale so just now the mayor received an
evacuation order for this city that
means all the residents here are going
to be asked to leave they're going to
organize buses to bring people out H the
government decided that um all the
citizen who live 5 kilometer from the
border will
evacuated more
[Music]
s
for you know the border with Lebanon is
just right across this mountain here and
the worry is as this war continues to
drag on and escalate that hisbah in the
north and Lebanon could easily make a a
Crossing into this area the same way
that Hamas made a
[Music]
Crossing
Z